une
[Musique]
non
un checkpoint bassin 100 m après le
village pour contrôler les passeports
c'est contraignant et puis on est
plusieurs à s'être allégé les passeports
et les avoir laissés dans les sacs avec
les porteurs on s'approche de la
frontière tibétaine je pense que c'est
un petit peu une zone stratégique et
sensible
je viens d'avoir le le hockey libérateur
du chef de groupe de ceux de daiwa
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tellement l'habitude
le dernière ils sont présents
de passe
jo
[Musique]
et c'est juste splendide c'est
incroyable on est entouré de donner du
tout et on a pu toucher la neige aussi
aujourd'hui sa cité c'était vrai
vachement coller la neige du népal s'ils
souhaitent
et
c'est super je pensais que j'allais
avoir mal à la tête ou mal au ventre et
en fait ça ça va aller chez plutôt super
heureuse quoi il n'y a pas de mots pour
décrire c'est vraiment magnifique et en
plus la ja la neige moi j'aurai revêtu
d'un message revêt toujours une bataille
de boules de neige et on a fait ça
aujourd'hui c'était super voilà et c'est
vraiment
[Musique]
caçapa et chaque fois c'est qui ce qui
part avec des des clients après d'autres
20 25 porter qui est bordée des choses
de clients et tout le monde du village
et ils sont très très content parce que
ça fait deux ans n'a pas de travail à
cause du coït dont ils sont très
contents d'eux avec doctor
aujourd'hui c'est obligé monter un petit
peu plus haut pour pratiquer pour demain
donc aujourd'hui on a monté jusqu'à 4000
et on a descendu jusqu'à 3800
aujourd'hui de ce mois de mobistar liste
richert 20 minutes il faut boire de
l'eau dont on pourra régler ce cas là le
premier quand je n'essaie 4400 après si
on est tout va bien on va jusqu'à 4700
de 4900 il n'est pas accessible ça c'est
un peu difficile parce qu'il a des
neiges dans n'a pas d'écran pendant ça
il faut oublier
[Musique]